[Music]
[Applause]
oh thank you
oh yeah
hey you're all right
fine thank you
lost my contact lens
hope you find
it electrical problems in the building
always the same isn't it
are we back on the fifth floor yes the
fifth my friend claire is here
i'm visiting her
she's expecting me
what's going on
[Music]
steven
[Music]
what are you are you like living inside
of me it's a little more complicated
[Music]
mark you look different
[Music]
we protect the vulnerable
and deliver justice
[Music]
this is the best worst day of my life
marvel studios moon night only on disney
plus
stephen
you weren't supposed to see any of this
what are you you sure you want to know
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
marvel studios night only on disney
floss
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
embrace it
[Music]
this chaos in here the fun of moon night
is getting introduced to a new superhero
in a new world
it's a real legitimate character study
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
moon knight is a spectacular character's
got an incredibly unique visual look
our job was to kind of put a lens on the
things that had the most uh dramatic
juice and ultimately take the mental
health aspect incredibly seriously
i am
stephen
the way we're tackling the story we
learn about stephen and then learn about
mark what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mark and they're the
same person
[Music]
the tone is like fight club meets
indiana jones it's a bit dark at times
to tie it into something so vast and
supernatural it's amazing
thank you
every aspect of this show has a duality
and we've shifted the paradigm
for me what's really exciting is that
it's totally unpredictable
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
[Music]
i'm losing it
we'll catch you on
your bloody useless
stevie stephen
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my dreams
thank you
lost the contact lens
hope you find it
thanks
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark
that must be very difficult
a voice in your head
shut up
this chaos
[Music]
embrace the chaos
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
you